[Applaudissements]
monsieur le prêt monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur Gabriel
Attal ministre chargé des comptes
publics monsieur le ministre quand Annie
d'algo maire de Paris s'est présenté en
mars 2020 elle avait proclamé deux
engagements le premier était qu'elle ne
serait pas candidate à l'élection
présidentielle la France entière alors
constaté qu'elle n'avait pas tenu parole
le second engagement a été fait la main
sur le cœur jamais elle n'augmenterait
les impôts des Parisiens or non
seulement elle l'a cessé de le faire
depuis 2014 mais cette semaine coûte
grâce les Parisiens apprennent d'une
manière pour le moins cavalière qu'elle
allait augmenter la taxe foncière de
plus de
50%, ceci pour tenter de sortir Paris du
chaos économique dans lequel elle se
trouve
la majorité de gauche avait pourtant
hérité ne vous en déplaise d'une
situation saine lors de l'alternance les
Parisiens sont excédés les services
publics ne sont pas à la hauteur d'une
grande métropole européenne Paris se
déclare cela étant dit cela étant dit
monsieur le ministre il n'est pas
envisageable que l'État en profite pour
porter atteinte aux libertés communales
et il n'est donc pas sérieux de parler
de mise sous tutelle ce il est temps que
le Président de la République
s'intéresse au cœur de la région
capitale je souhaiterais donc que vous
m'indiquiez monsieur le ministre par
quelle mesure particulière votre
gouvernement compte soulager les
Parisiens qui devront de surcroît faire
des efforts dans la perspective des Jeux
olympiques de 2024